LEE DENISON: Hello,
and welcome.
Thanks for coming to this talk
on Google+ Sign-In for Android
Developers.
My name is Lee Denison.
I am a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Google+
Developer Relations team.
And with me on stage, I have Wes
Tarle, who is a software
engineer on the Google+
platform.
So eight weeks ago, we announced
Google+ Sign-In as
the way for developers to
integrate Google as a social
identity platform.
And with it, we launched some
amazing features for Android
developers which help you to
create a more engaging
experience for your users, and
to grow your audience by
providing new ways to do sharing
that make it easy for
your users and their circles
to reengage with your app.
So out of interest, how many
people in the audience are
Android developers?
Great.
I'm in the right place.
And how many of you have
integrated a Google API with
your Android app?
OK.
A bunch of you.
Excellent.
OK, final question.
How many people have already
integrated Google+ Sign-In
with your app?
OK.
A couple.
Not many.
That's fine.
Great.
So I think there's something
in this talk for everybody.
I'm going to introduce you,
along with where's the new
features in Google+ Sign-In, and
then we're going to show
you just how simple it is
to integrate Google+
Sign-In into your app.
And along the way, we'll point
out some of the things that
you might want to think
about when you come
to do this for real.
So Google+ Sign-In is available
on the web,
Android, and iOS.
And although I'm going to focus
on Android in this talk,
I want to start with a feature
which is actually implemented
as part of web sign in, and
that's the ability for you to
offer your Android app as part
of the web sign in flow.
And we call that over
the air installs.
So in this example, which is
TuneIn that have integrated
Google+ Sign-In, it's
a cool service.
It lets me listen to my favorite
radio stations on the
web and mobile platforms.
But let's imagine
that I discover
TuneIn via their website.
They, of course, are going to
want to offer me their Android
app as part of the
sign in flow.
And with Google+ Sign-In, they
can do exactly that.
So seamlessly, as part of the
sign in flow, when I come to
their site for the very first
time, Google will show me a
dialog box which looks just like
this, but only if I have
a compatible Android device,
and only if I don't already
have TuneIn installed.
Importantly, if I--
It'll be waiting for me.
I will already be signed
in to that device.
When I launch TuneIn for the
first time, I'll already be
signed in without having
to do anything.
And that's because Google+
Sign-In authenticates the user
to the service, and not
to individual devices.
That makes this process probably
the most seamless app
install process that
you've seen.
And from the user's perspective,
it's completely
like magic.
Just to show you how simple it
is to integrate over the air
installs with your web service,
if you've already
added the web sign in button
to your website, it's
literally a one line change to
add an Android package that
you want to install as
part of the over
the air install process.
You literally just say which
package you want to install.
Now, I'm not going to talk more
about how to integrate
Google+ Sign-In with
websites here.
But if you get a chance
to catch [INAUDIBLE]
talk later on this afternoon,
he'll be covering
that in more detail.
So let's cover some
of the basics.
Google+ Sign-In is provided as
part of Google Play Services,
which means it already
enjoys a huge install
base of Android devices.
And you as a developer can get
hold of the libraries you need
directly from the Android SDK.
As well as providing the APIs
for Google+ Sign-In, Google
Play Services also provides
native API access for the
Google+ APIs, and a growing
number of other Google APIs.
Google+ Sign-In integrates
with the Android account
manager, which means it uses
the user accounts that are
already on the device.
And that means that the user
doesn't have to keep typing
their username and password,
because they authenticate with
the device, and not with
each individual app.
That's great for them, because
we all know that if you've
chosen a strong password, then,
by definition, it's
difficult to type on
a mobile keyboard.
And it's great for your app,
because it means more of your
users are signed in.
Google+ Sign-In is implemented
on top of OAuth 2.0, but it
really is the easiest
implementation of OAuth 2.0
that you'll come across.
It does all the heavy lifting
for you, and it takes care of
all of the OAuth 2.0 exchanges
that you need to do, and all
of the token management-- so
the token caching and the
refreshing.
And if you do you want to use a
Google API which is not part
of Google Play Services,
you can still do that.
All you need to do is include
the scopes when you set up the
+ client in the first place,
and then you can grab that
token and use it with
rest APIs and
other client libraries.
So I just want to show you
quickly what it looks like
when the user signs in with
Google+ Sign-In for the first
time on an Android device.
And I'm going to use this
example from Banjo.
When I click the Sign In button,
I get this native
consent dialog.
Now, as a developer, you don't
need to worry about that.
That's implemented as part
of Google Play Services.
And because it's native, it
keeps the user in the app, and
it shows the user in a clear
and consistent fashion what
permissions are being
requested by
the app from them.
Now, when we were creating
Google+ Sign-In, we asked
users what they were most
interested in from a social
identity provider.
And they came back to us with
two major concerns.
Firstly, they wanted to be sure
that when they sign into
an app with a social identity
provider that it wouldn't
result in their friends
getting spammed.
And second, they wanted to be
sure that the app activities
that were written by the app
they were signing in to, they
would have control over
who gets to see those.
So we worked really hard with
Google+ Sign-In to make sure
that the user stays in control,
and that's what this
dialog is about.
So the line items that appear
on this permissions dialog
will depend on which scopes
you've asked of the user.
What we're showing here is the
default scope, which is
plus.login, and that gives your
app access to the user's
basic profile information, which
means their name, their
ID, their profile picture, and
any information they've chosen
to make public on
their profile.
It also gives you access
to their social graph.
But of course, although that
defaults to the user's entire
social graph, they have the
option to customize that.
So if they click the link that
says change who this app can
see, they get to customize which
circles are provided to
the graph to the app.
And although the app doesn't
actually get to see the names
of the circles themselves, it'll
get a list of all the
users in those.
Lastly, the item at the bottom
there allows us to control who
gets to see app activities which
are written by this app.
And again, it defaults to your
circles, but there's a really
clear up front option there that
allows you to keep them
private if you select
only you.
Of course, you can
customize those.
If I have climbing buddies and
I have a climbing app, then
this allows me to
keep those app
activities focused and relevant.
So Google+ Sign-In gives
you access to all that
information, but what I'm going
to do now is hand over
to Wes, and he's going to show
us just how easy it is to
implement it in our app.
WESLEY TARLE: So let's see how
we add the Sign-In with Google
to our existing Android app.
We're going to add a Sign In
button to our layout, and then
we'll add to our activity a Plus
client and bind that to
the activities life cycle.
So to add the button, we're
just going to make a plain
layout change.
The Sign In button is just a
plain Android view that you
can add to any layout, but it
has inside it all of the
resources and assets that you
need to match Google branding
guidelines, and it has
translated text, so that you
can launch the button
on any language.
In our activity, we'll add a
Plus client, and this is going
to be our main context for
interacting with Google+ APIs
on Android.
So we recommend that each
activity has a Plus client so
that you can be sure that
while the Plus client
resources are in use, that
you have an actual user
engaged in your app.
So let's tie that Plus client
to or activity life cycle.
In OnCreate, we'll
initialize it.
And then in OnStart,
we'll connect.
And in OnStop, we'll
disconnect.
We'll use the Plus client
builder to initialize it.
So this is where you can figure
how you're going to use
Google APIs with the
Plus client.
And here we'll declare a couple
different kinds of
activities that we'd
like to send on the
user's behalf to Google.
Now, these will show up in the
consent dialog, so you'll want
to make sure that you only
choose the types of activity
that your app's going to send,
so you don't confuse the user
when they see the consent.
If you're using other Google
APIs like Drive or YouTube,
this is where you'd specify
their OAuth scopes.
And you'll notice that
we don't mention an
account name here.
Google Play services takes care
of keeping the user's
identity for your app so that
you don't have to show an
account chooser unless
you want to.
Once we have the Plus
client initialized,
we'll connect an OnStart.
And this does two things.
First, it sets up a service
connection between your app
and Google Play services, and
then it auto logs in the user
in case you signed in before
on the web or to your app.
So you'll want to make sure to
call connect in OnStart so you
can capture all of those users
that came to your app from our
sign in and OTA flow who are
already signed in to Google.
This will let them sign into
your app just seamlessly.
In OnStop, we'll call
disconnect, and this is
important to clean up any
resources that are used, both
by the Plus client and
your activity.
So you'll be releasing the
service connections here, and
the service connection
will also be
releasing your activity.
So you really have to call
disconnect every time you call
connect so that you
don't leak.
Now, the connect call
doesn't show any UI.
That's sort of up to you.
We wanted to make sure that you
could send the user to the
consent screen when
you wanted.
When you call connect, you can
expect one of two callbacks.
If the user is already signed in
on the web or to your app,
you'll get OnConnected, and here
we can start using all of
the Google+ APIs provided
by the Plus client.
So we get the current person,
and we can update our UI right
here on the main thread.
If the user's not signed in yet,
then generally, that's
because they need a
consent screen.
And we tell you about that
consent screen by giving you a
pending intent wrapped inside
this connection result.
So we'll call you back with
OnConnectionFailed with the
connection result.
And since we have a sign in
button, we're just going to
stash that connection result
away until the user clicks it.
But if you were showing a
loading screen or a splash
screen, you could start it
directly here to show the user
the consent and get signed
into the app.
So the sign in button is a plain
Android view, and we've
attached our activity as
an OnClick listener.
When the user clicks the button,
we're going to start
the resolution, and then expect
a call to OnActivity
result with whether the user
signed in or not in the
consent screen.
So in our OnClick method, if we
have a connection result,
because we've got the
OnConnectionFailed callback,
we'll call
StartResolutionForResult.
And this just wraps the call to
the pending intent so that
you don't have to understand how
to call a pending intent.
It's kind of rough syntax.
Then we'll get a callback to
OnActivityResult, and if the
user consented, we'll
get a result OK.
We'll connect the Plus client
again, and expect an
OnConnected callback.
If the user canceled, then we'll
get a result cancel, and
we'll just hang out and
wait until they click
on the button again.
So you can see it's just a few
lines of code on top of what
you've already got in your
activity to get a user signed
in and get access to
our Google+ APIs.
LEE DENISON: Awesome.
So now we've got the
user signed in.
What can we do to enhance their
experience in our app?
Well, there's a few answers
to that question, and the
simplest, from a Google+
perspective, would be to take
the user's name and profile
picture andmake them feel at
home in our app.
Well, something you can do which
is even more powerful
would be to take the user's
social graph and integrate it
with your own data model,
and use that to provide
interesting or useful insights
into your data for the user.
That's often termed in the
industry social proof.
So here we have a great
example from Fancy.
They have a stream which pulls
in stuff from all over the
world that people find
cool and interesting,
and show it to me.
Now, that's a potentially
huge data set.
But if they integrate that
stream with my social graph to
filter it and to order it, then
not only am I much more
likely to see things that I find
cool and interesting, but
I'm also much more likely to
engage when I see that one of
my friends has engaged.
If [INAUDIBLE]
thinks that these shoes are
cool, they must be cool.
So Google+ Sign-In gives
you access to the
user's social graph.
And what I'm going to do now
is I'll had it over to Wes,
and he'll show us after we've
got the user signed in how we
get access to that
information.
WESLEY TARLE: So once the user's
signed in and you have
a connected Plus client, it's
really easy to get access to
their social graph.
What we're going to do is call
LoadPeople, and then expect a
call back to OnPeopleLoaded.
And that's it.
This pattern of making a request
directly from your
activity and then getting a
call back later with the
result is common to all the
APIs across Google Play
Services, and you'll see this
in all of our Google+ APIs.
So we'll call LoadPeople and
pass the visible collection.
This is the set of people that
your app is allowed to see in
the user's social circles.
If we were configuring it for
best ordering, if you wanted
to get close ties, you would set
that here, or alphabetical
ordering, if you care.
Then we get a call to
OnPeopleLoaded.
And here, if we're successful,
then we'll get the people
directly in a person buffer.
Now, a person buffer is a lot
like a cursor in terms of
efficiency, so it's important
that you close
it when you're done.
So you'll see here that we have
the regular try finally
block the you'd expect from a
cursor, where we close the
cursor in the finally.
It's better than a cursor,
though, because you get actual
native typed access to
the data inside it.
So you can iterate through these
people, and they're just
exposed as a person
model object.
So you can get their display
name and their image in a very
natural Java way.
And this really points to the
power of Google Play Services
to deliver an API to your app,
since you didn't have to
decide what kind of HTTP stack
you wanted or JSON parsing.
Google handles Auth and offline
and caching and
batching so that you really
just have access to this
online data in a very native
way, directly in your activity
where you need to
update your UI.
And I think that's
really cool.
LEE DENISON: So it really is
very simple to integrate
Google+ Sign-In with your app.
But of course, when you come to
do this for real, there'll
be a bunch of broader concerns
that you need to take into
account for your app.
So, for example, if your app
integrates with a back end
service, as many of them will,
then you need to consider
issues like, how do you
pass the user's
identity between them?
And if you're going to make
calls to third party APIs,
Google or otherwise, where
are they made from?
Are they made service side?
Are they made client side?
If you choose to integrate
multiple identity providers,
as many of you will, then you
need to think about how you
harmonize the data models
between them, and also how you
deal with some of the special
cases that arise when a user
can present multiple identities
to your app.
Now, I'm not going to go into
details of those here, but
what I do want to do is call
out some of the other talks
that are going on at Google IO
this year, where we cover
those issues in greater
detail.
So if you're interested in
those, check those out.
Now, for the stats
geeks, we haven't
forgotten about the analytics.
So when you create your app,
you create a project which
allows you to use the Google+
APIs and the Sign In API, and
you have the option, at that
point, to associate your
project with a Plus page.
If you do that, then you'll get
access to analytics for
Google+ Sign-In.
Now, this is a sample
app of mine.
And clearly, I can see I need to
do a bit more work, because
I've only got 83 users
signing in.
But here, you can see how many
people are signing into your
app using Google+ Sign-In.
You can see how many versions
of your app have been
installed via over the air
installs, and who's using some
of the new features that we're
about to talk about-- so app
activities and interactive
posts.
So check this out.
It's a really great tool to see
the impact of integrating
Google+ Sign-In in your app.
So now I want to talk about one
of the new features that
we've launched with Google+
Sign-In, which
is interactive posts.
Interactive posts add action to
Google+ posts in a way that
makes it easy for users and
their circles to re-engage
with your app.
So we're used to the idea, with
a traditional Google+
post, of having a
content target.
So if you include a content
target with your post, then
Google will go and fetch
some metadata, a title,
description, a picture, and
create a target in your post
which is clickable and
takes the user to
the original content.
With interactive posts, we've
added an action target-- a
second target in the form of
a call to action button.
And that takes the user not only
to the content, but also,
then, performs an action
when they get there.
So if I see a post like this in
my stream on mobile, and I
click that button, it will
launch your app, it will
provide your app with the
information it needs to take
me to the content I've
requested, and then it will
tell it that I want to perform
an action, and
your app can do that.
So that, for me as a user,
is a seamless experience.
It takes me directly where I
want to go, and it makes it
incredibly easy for me to act.
So we're seeing huge increases
in levels of user interaction
rate with these posts, so I
would really encourage you to
check them out.
If a traditional post inspires
user curiosity, then
interactive posts get
their attention.
So I'll walk you through
an example.
Let's imagine that I'm using
TuneIn in on my Android
device, and I want to--
with him.
In TuneIn, I click the Share
button as I would anyway, and
it fires an intent which
launches the share dialog
within the Google+
app as normal.
Now, when they do that, they
would provide some extra
information that includes in the
intent that they want to
include a call to action
button-- in this case, listen.
So you can see, as normal,
they're able to pre-populate
the text, and you can see that
I get the preview, including
the listen button.
Now, because I'm sharing that
directly with Wes, he will get
a notification via the Google
notifier, not just on his
mobile device, but across
all Google properties.
So on search, on
Gmail, on Maps.
Let's imagine that he clicks
the notification
on his mobile device.
So he's taken in, and he sees
the post on the G+ stream on
his Android device.
There, he can see the listen
button, and when he clicks it,
that fires an intent which will
start the TuneIn app, and
it will include the information
which was inserted
right at the beginning that
tells the TuneIn app how to
get to the content, and
the fact that I
want to start listening.
So the next thing that
happens, from Wes's
perspective, is that he's
listening to the music and
trying to understand why he
ever listens to me when it
comes to my taste.
So that's all great.
What happens if he doesn't have
the TuneIn app installed?
Well, instead, he's taken to the
app store, to the TuneIn
page, and he has the ability
to install that app.
When he clicks install, it
downloads and installs as
normal, and he gets an Android
notification that allows him
to complete the action that he
started in the first place.
He clicks on that, and again,
from his perspective, the next
thing that happens is he's
listening to the music.
So that Play store flow only
happens if he doesn't have the
app installed, but it's really
powerful, because it gives
your users the tools when
they're most excited about
your service to share their
excitement in a way that makes
it easy for new users
and their circles to
engage with your app.
So I'm now going to hand back to
Wes, and he's going to show
us how to add an interactive
post to our app.
WESLEY TARLE: So first I'll
show you how to generate
interactive posts with deep link
IDs, and then I'll show
you how to handle clicks on
those posts on Android to take
the user deep into your app.
So you might be familiar with
the standard actions send
intent on Android.
That's the standard way to send
snippets of text and URLs
and images and everything
else from app to app.
So we built on top of
action send in a
couple important ways.
First, we added support
for deep link IDs.
And just like a web URL can
link deeply to a page on a
website, a deep link ID can link
directly into an activity
and action inside your
Android app.
Second, we added support
to specify a
call to action button.
Now, this is that button that
drives engagement on your
posts that takes the user to
some action inside your app.
So to create that interactive
post, let's say that I want to
share some music with Lee to
improve his taste in music.
I'm going to create a post by
first setting up the content,
and I'll set a URL like
I did before, and I'll
set a deep link ID.
This deep link ID, when Lee
interacts with the post, will
be sent back to your app
and round tripped.
So you want to make sure that
it uniquely identifies some
content in your app, and that
it's meaningful to anyone who
might see the post.
Now that we've got the content
configured, we'll add the call
to action button.
And here, I choose listen,
because I want Lee to listen
to the song.
But there are a hundred or so
other actions that you could
choose and apply to the same
button from your app.
So depending on what your app
does with that action target,
we're going to choose
the verb.
Now, similarly to the content,
I'll choose a URL for the web
and a deep link ID for mobile,
and that's iOS and Android.
I build an intent by calling
GetIntent, and then call
StartActivityForResult to
launch the share box.
Then the user can configure who
it's going to share to.
I would include Lee,
and then hit post.
So now that we have interactive
posts with deep
links in the Google+
stream, how do you
handle clicks on Android?
We're going to export exactly
one activity that exists only
as a control to parse the deep
link ID, and then choose the
right activity and action inside
our app, and then send
the user there.
And that's it.
So we'll declare it in our
Android manifest, and set
exported equals true.
Then we'll add this
intent filter.
This intent filter comes
directly from our developer
documentation, and you just
paste it in here.
And the intent filter plus
your package name is what
tells Google that your app's
installed and ready to handle
deep link IDs.
Let's look at the
implementation of this activity.
In OnCreate, we're going to
parse the deep link ID, and
then decide, was this deep link
from a content or from a
call to action button?
So if it was from a call to
action button, we'll include
an extra in our intent that we
can tell our song activity to
go ahead and start playing when
it receives the intent.
Then we call StartActivity on
the intent that we built.
And this is the important part--
that we call Finish
directly here in OnCreate.
And that way, this activity
won't show any flicker to the
user, and the user won't
know it was there.
So everything else, including
generating notifications
across Google properties and
installing your app from the
Play store is all handled by
Google, so it kind of gets it
out of the way, and it lets you
create posts that are more
engaging for your users and
focus on what you're going to
do with that.
LEE DENISON: Awesome.
So I want to finish up by
talking about one last feature
that we've launched with Google+
Sign-In, and that is
app activities.
So app activities allow you,
with your app, with user
consent, to write activity
to Google.
So that might be music that the
users listen to, movies
they've watched, places they've
checked in, or on
Shazam, songs that
I've discovered.
Now, the first place that
we chose to surface app
activities was on the
user's profile.
So if someone in my circles
takes a look at my profile,
because I've given them
permission, they can see the
songs that I've discovered
on Shazam.
And if they click those links,
it will take them through to
the original content
on Shazam.
So the moment those activities
contain deep links as well.
Two weeks ago, we announced a
new place that we're going to
start surfacing app activities,
and that's on
Google Search.
So if, for example, I search on
Google Search for Fandango,
in this case, then I get the
normal organic search results
on the left, and on the right,
I'll see a social card.
Now, that already appears.
And as now, because Fandango
have an active Google+
presence, I'll see there how
many people are following
their Plus page, and I'll have
the ability to follow their
Plus page directly from
that social card.
The bit that we're going to
add is the next bit-- the
Popular With Google+ Users.
So this is an aggregated
anonymized context for
Fandango that tells me what's
going on based on the app
activities that their users are
writing from their app.
Now, that's great for the user,
because it means that
when I search for Fandango, I
get extra context before I've
even clicked through
to their site.
And from Fandango's point of
view, it's great for them
because users that click on that
content in that social
card will have already chosen
that they want to interact
with one of their pieces
of content.
So they're getting highly
qualified users coming through
to their app.
So we're really excited at
Google about app activities,
and this really just represents
the start.
So I would encourage you to take
a look at them and watch
this space.
So I'm going to give you back to
Wes, and he's going to show
us how easy it is to add app
activities to our app.
WESLEY TARLE: So once you have
a signed in user, it's really
simple to send app activity
to Google.
So let's say, in this case,
I've sent Lee a post about
listening to some music,
and he's started to
listen to the music.
And now, we're going to record
app activities that are Listen
activities to record the fact
that he is listening to music
in our app.
First, we want to configure
the content.
This is going to be a target,
for the moment.
On Android, app activities
are called moments.
I don't know if you've ever
tried to name a model class
activity on Android, but
it's not a good idea.
So we specify the content
using this item scope.
And item scope is a really wide
interface, because it's
meant to support any type of
content that your might write.
But the important bits
here are the ID.
That's going to be a deep link
ID, just like we had in the
interactive post case.
It's going to have some
meaning to your app.
And then the type.
In our case, the tape
is music recording.
So we're listening to a song.
Then, given that type, we'll
set some metadata here.
We'll set the title, and the
description, and the
thumbnail, so that
Google knows how
to render this thing.
Now that we have the content
configured, we'll create a
moment that has an activity
and the content.
So since we listened
to the song, we can
write a listen activity.
Now, it's really important that
this listen activity--
we mentioned it on an earlier
slide when we were configuring
our Plus client.
This way, Lee has already
consented to send listen
activities to Google, so we know
that we can write these
activities in a passive way.
We build the moment, and then
we call WriteMoment.
And WriteMoment is really cool,
because the same way
that you called LoadPeople and
Google Play Services took care
of everything, WriteMoment
takes care of offline.
So if you have assigned
a user, and you call
WriteMoment, and the user's
offline, the next time they go
online, the moment
will be written.
And this is really cool, because
with Google Play
Services, we can offer the sort
of deeper integration and
more complex stuff.
LEE DENISON: Cool.
Thanks very much.
So as you can see, integrating
Google+ Sign-In is incredibly
easy, and it includes a bunch of
great features for Android
developers.
It helps you to enhance the
experience for users in your
app by providing personalization
data and
access to their social graph.
It helps you to grow your
audience through targeted
sharing-- any features in
interactive posts--
and it makes it really easy for
users to get your app with
features like over
the air install.
So if you'd like to know more,
we're going to hold a panel
discussion upstairs right after
this session with some
of the partners that have
integrated Google+ Sign-In
into their Android apps.
So please come up and have
a chat with us up there.
But thank you very much
for listening.
If you want to find out more,
take a look at our developer
documentation at
developers.google.com/plus.
There you'll find great
documentation, but also
samples, including our quick
starts that'll get you up and
running with this stuff
in just five minutes.
We're going to hold a code lab
tomorrow, where we take you
from nothing to a server side
component and an Android
client which has integrated
Google+
Sign-In in just two hours.
I'll be running that along with
my colleague, Gus Class.
And Wes will be there as well.
So if you're interested, please
come along to that.
And we would very much like your
feedback, so use the QR
code on the slide or the one
over by the door, and you can
give us feedback about
this session.
Wes and I would love
to hear from you.
We've got a few minutes to take
some questions, so if you
would like to ask a question,
please do so, but
come up to the mics.
Thank you very much
for your time.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a quick question.
If you want your app to use
another scope-- like, to get
tasks or something else--
LEE DENISON: Can I get you
to speak up slightly?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: You hear me?
LEE DENISON: Yep.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: So if you want your
app to use something like
another scope--
like Tasks or something that,
how do you handle the token?
Do you have to cache it,
or how does it work?
LEE DENISON: So that will
depend on your app.
As you saw in the examples, you
create this Plus client,
and you have the option to add
scopes at the point that you
create the Plus client.
Once you've done that, you can
use Google Auth Utils to pull
out the token.
And that's an access token, so
it's long lived for the length
of an access token.
Depending on how you want to
access it, you may need to
cache it yourself.
At the point that you've pulled
the token out, you do
have to manage it yourself.
So at some point, you may start
to get 401s or 403s,
because the token has expired,
at which point you'll need to
use Google Play Services
to get another token.
And then if you want
to add anything--
AUDIENCE: So it works exactly
the same way as the Google
Authentication Service like
Play services right now?
Like, you don't want to use
Google+, but you just use the
authentication service like
the usual dialog with the
Google accounts and
stuff like that?
WESLEY TARLE: Yeah.
So once you connect to your
Plus client with the state
where you have all
of your scopes
specified, the user's consented.
So when you use Google Auth Util
to get a token, you get
one without any kind of user
interaction required.
So there won't be any
notifications or anything
after that.
That token's cached for an hour
on the client for you, so
anytime you make a call
to GetToken, you
can use that token.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
And my other quick question is
what's the flow if the user's
not registered in
Google+ at all?
What do you show when you--
LEE DENISON: So if the user's
not registered in Google+,
then they'll be taken to the
Google+ app, and they'll have
the option to upgrade.
So there is an upgrade flow.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So does this work?
Yeah.
My question is, are we required
to use the Google+
Sign-In for our layouts, or
can we just make our own
button without the
Google+ branding?
LEE DENISON: So the Google+
button is provided really for
convenience.
I mean, from your perspective,
one of the things that you
need to consider is that a lot
of reasons why people want to
use Google as a social identity
provider is because
they trust it.
And so by using our branding,
you help to confer the level
of trust to the user.
But if you want to use your own
button, you're entirely
welcome to do so.
One of the main advantages of
using the Google+ button is
that it provides all the
localization for you.
So that makes it very easy.
But no, there's absolutely no
reason why you can't use your
own button.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So segueing on that a
little bit, what I find that
I'm experiencing is I'm trying
to integrate Google+ within
Enterprise.
But I kind of don't want to
make it seem too social,
because I wouldn't want the
client to feel like they're
exposing their internal
communications.
LEE DENISON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: But the infrastructure
of Google+ is
well done, very good to
associate the users and create
a great experience for what
we're trying to do in terms of
getting a company who has
individuals on different
coasts to integrate within
an experience.
Is there anything or anywhere or
anyone you can suggest that
can provide some guidelines for
Google+ within Enterprise
without it seeming
too playful, for
lack of a better word?
LEE DENISON: So that's quite
a broad question.
What I'd encourage you to do,
actually, is to come over to
the sandbox after the
session, and we can
talk in more detail.
We've only got a minute, so it's
quite a broad question to
answer right now.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool beans.
LEE DENISON: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What if a user had
multiple account and he switch
between this account,
if your application
can know about that?
LEE DENISON: Sorry, can I get
you to speak up slightly?
AUDIENCE: What if user have
multiple accounts and he
switch between this account,
if there's any chance
application know about that?
LEE DENISON: So the question is,
how do you handle multiple
accounts with Google+ Sign-In?
So in the case of Android
specifically, if the device
has multiple accounts on it,
then the very first time
someone tries to sign in, the
pending intent-- so the
connection result that we
saw in the examples--
will contain a pending
intent that
displays an account chooser.
So the user gets to pick which
account they want to sign in
with at that point.
Now, at that point, a default
account for the app be
decided, and that will stay the
default account every time
they open the app until they
choose to sign out.
So if you take a look at our
examples, one of the things
that we recommend you do is that
when the user signs out,
you clear the default account
for that app, at which point,
the next time someone tries to
sign in, you'll, again, get
the account chooser, and
they can pick the one
they want to use.
I don't know if you have
anything to add to that.
WESLEY TARLE: No,
that's about it.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
LEE DENISON: OK, we've got
one more question.
AUDIENCE: This one's
pretty easy.
I didn't notice, when you're
first coming into the app,
what can I use to determine
if I should even
show the sign in button?
How do I know if they're
already signed in?
LEE DENISON: How do you know
they're already signed in?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so you're
saying, here's how you show
the sign in button.
If they're already signed
in, I don't need to.
LEE DENISON: So if you tie the
life cycle of the Plus client
object to your activity, the
way we suggested here, then
when you call start or you call
ConnectOnStart, the Plus
client will actually try to
authenticate the user
immediately.
And if they are signed in, it
will return you straightaway
to OnConnected.
So if you've built your flow
so that when you get
OnConnected back, you've
displayed the sign in
experience, then as soon as they
come into the app, you'll
get that call.
So it should work from
your app's design.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
LEE DENISON: Sure.
No problem.
All right, thanks
very much, guys.
If you've got any more
questions, please come over
and have a chat in
the sandbox area.
Thank you.